[Music]
i'm talking today with greg hurwitz
president of los angeles california
uh former student of mine from harvard
and uh
someone i've known for a long time
greg's a novelist and
although he has very many other
occupations which we'll talk about today
uh it's a pleasure to see you greg it's
been a while since we talked
good to see you too jordan maybe we
could start by you just outlining some
of the things that you do and then
i think we'll focus on the political
stuff more today not necessarily from a
political perspective though
well i came in from novels i'm a
novelist all right the orphan x series
um and i've also worked in screenplays
and tv and comics and some other
stuff and i started to get involved in
politics
around 2016 um in large part because
before that i kind of thought democracy
would be fine without me i didn't really
feel any responsibilities as a citizen i
kind of had a lot of opinions but didn't
do a whole lot about it
um and one of the things that i wanted
to do
when donald trump was elected i was
he was not a candidate or a president
to my liking or who is a match with my
value set and the first thing that i ask
myself it's funny you give that lecture
about the old testament that
one of the answers that that old
testament answers is always like god's
angry we screwed up
and so i really took that approach all
the way down i thought rather than
starting to
go on offense and and tackle people who
voted or thought differently the mayor
had different ideologies i would try and
think about
the failings of the democratic party the
status quo
all the parts of society that i was part
of and how badly we would have
to have fallen short for him to be seen
as a
viable and preferable alternative to the
candidate that we were putting forth
and so i started to work with a lot of
candidates i was mostly interested in
candidates in
purple districts talking to red voters
right and so for the midterms we work
with 30 candidates democrat and
in deep red districts talking about
making good faith arguments the way it's
supposed to be
right i have an opinion i have a a
preference in political party
to make good faith arguments to people
to try and to try and win them over to a
different point of view
we had a lot of success we i'd say that
the 30 candidates that we work with 21-1
in terms of flipping those seats well
you all have foreign viewers here so
when you talk about deep red states deep
blue states purple states
what do you mean uh republican versus
democrat right i wasn't interested in
figuring out how
i wasn't i'm not interested in any
conversations that take place
in the bubble uh of like-minded people
um so i was interested in races in
oklahoma and new mexico
and ohio and uh you know virginia and so
we really went there and long story
short off that we started to i wrote a
bunch of op-eds i wrote one with you for
the wall street journal
um and i did a lot for the bulwark
trying to talk across the aisle and i
went out and talked to
i think about a 360 degree arc of
americans whether it was military
evangelicals
black lives matter you know hispanic you
know
texas mexicans different population than
you know
miami cubans right different population
from california mexicans and really
talking to different groups and
listening and figuring it out and i
wound up doing about 200 digital and
television commercials
um all this political orcas pro bono
with a with a small team of us
here yeah do you want to describe the
team yeah i
i it's it was it's me it's marshall
hirschkovetz who's a tv
show runner and creator he created
30-something billy ray
oscar-nominated screenwriter he wrote
you know captain phillips he just did
the comey rule
shawn ryan the creator of the shield the
tv producer and lita calagras
um she you know has a ton of credits
from
shutter island to uh you know she worked
on
avatar and wrote a good amount of that
with james cameron and what was
interesting was
in terms of the hollywood system like
you know after trump was elected i think
the democrats were
humbled and then they're always kind of
willing to meet with hollywood people
but the washout rate was
was uh there weren't a lot of people who
were interested in having different
kinds of conversations and i decided if
i could actually get in front of
democratic leadership and marshall too
was on that first trip with me
that i would say exactly what i thought
all the time to the best of my ability
okay so let me let me walk through this
so
um a couple of years ago maybe that was
in 2016 about
yeah you had some political awakening
let's say and i guess that was
attendant on trump's election and your
response to that was
how did the democrats sink so low as to
allow this to happen
is that a reasonable way of summarizing
it
rather what the hell is wrong with all
those trump voters
yeah and like what let me start to
explore in earnest
my confirmation biases and blind spots
and talk to
everybody who has a different
perspective or point of view than me
in earnest to try to figure that out
yeah well you guys decided that you were
going to produce
messages for the democrat party
yeah and that's that was to do that on
your own accord in some sense or on your
own
on your own on your own but also
independently
yeah i mean the line we used was and i
remember sitting in my living room
talking about this i said we asked for
no money no credit and no permission and
you said
to me that's exactly what orphan x does
my
my protagonist of my thriller series it
was this really funny confluence of my
political life and the things that i was
writing in the fiction world
and what we realized is we can't go we
couldn't go through everything we did
was on our own we raised our own money
we
one of the things we realized is the
cost of admission for getting through
messaging that i thought was a more more
persua
making good faith persuasion arguments
but also that was fair
every single economic fact that i put in
any of the 200 commercials that i
produced
i ran through a friend of mine who's
like a wall street republican like i
always wanted opposition fact testing
we tried to do nothing fair that wasn't
fair i'm not suggesting we got this
right all the time
but i tried to not do i didn't want ads
that went after
trump's kids in certain ways that were
off bounds and personal i was trying you
know because look you're if you're
if you're messaging and making
propaganda
is really what it is that's that's
google's you're in goebbels
arena that's dangerous stuff you got to
take it really really seriously
to try to engage and make arguments
without getting
corrupted by what that is in the world
well that's that's why it's dangerous is
that you don't understand people don't
understand when they start to mess with
the truth that they're starting to mess
with their own psyches
because you if you start playing in the
domain of deceit
you'll get tangled up in that so fast
and make your head spin and then
you undo yourself i mean you can undo
yourself even if you stick pretty close
to the truth
okay so i mean what happened what what
you guys did and the way you went about
it
has struck me is quite i don't know
unbelievable
i guess and that's why i want to dwell
on it a bit so
you decided that you had a political
responsibility you organized yourself
with a group of people
what a group that was much larger to
begin with but that shrank quickly to
those that were actually
dedicated over some long period of time
to putting a lot of work into this
and it's not surprising you got a bunch
of attrition as a consequence of that
then you decided that you would make
messages that were in alignment with the
at least in principle with the
democratic party but
you didn't get permission from the party
brass so to speak
to do that you did that independently
well there's a weird
well two things about the attrition rate
one of them was i quickly discovered
that a lot of people who are interested
in the sort of loudest online outrage
are equally devoted to the status quo as
the opposition
and so one of the things i came to very
quickly was it matters much more
much more important than language
policing right and permission structures
of who's allowed to say what
is an orientation on people's intentions
and the actual outcomes
and that's one way you can assess the
groups of people of whether someone's
going to be useful if you roll up your
sleeves and get in
actually get something done whether
that's winning a race in
oklahoma right or trying to talk in good
faith and respectfully to voters in
western pennsylvania
it's going to be messy you have to
there's no
if i describe that what do you mean
messy like what's messy about it
we've talked a little bit about the
psychological consequences of this
this kind of action even these kinds of
discussions
by messi i mean i mean good meaning
i don't i'm the the further along i get
with this the more convinced i am that
you cannot have
a perfect conversation that where
everyone is is contained and all the
language goes seamlessly
about race about gender and about class
in america
and so when there's too much
constriction around language from the
left
and and or from the right basically it's
they're barking around the perimeter of
the fertile solutions
they're barking around the perimeter to
make sure that nobody can have the kinds
of conversations that you need to have
you have to talk about those things
imperfectly you have to so why would be
why wouldn't people be motivated to not
allow that to happen do you think
well because that look so for the uh
there there's different skus and
everything is a generalization right so
i'm gonna generalize a little bit
i think that that there's in the far
right
we see a kind of corruption and
ossification around
sort of donald trump and what he
represents but he was saying things that
hit people in a way that
that were things that they weren't
allowed to say i have a whole bunch of
theories about the republicans i'm going
to
keep it focused on my looking in the
proverbial mirror
i think that a lot of the language
policing of the left is actually a way
to maintain
the status quo because what status quo
and to whose advantage let's say that
you're
a rich hollywood elite
much like me right or you know
or somebody who is who is in in the
kinds of groups that uh that i move in
that that that you move in but let's say
further left of you like i am
or more you know we're both liberal but
if you can pull if you can talk and have
all of the lingo and know exactly what
the permission structures are and you
say
latinx instead of latino and you do all
this stuff and in a way what you're
doing is
you're you're making sure that the
conversations that are the real
conversations that bring
change that are messier don't
necessarily occur but if you have all
the language down you can sort of
maintain
your position and your money and your
relative stature
yeah so you can you can assume that if
there was a solution that was being
proposed you'd be
part of the solution and not part of the
problem you single that with
you signal that with the language but
you're also you're
you're you're casting like look i made a
i'll give you an example i made a video
about
the for me i was i was exceedingly
opposed from day one to
messages of chaos from the democratic
party right i think conservatives
particularly have a reaction to
uh to chaos i think they have a
legitimate reaction when people announce
sort of you know police-free zones in
seattle and
in portland and from day one i was
saying this whole notion of sanctuary
cities doesn't make sense to me for a
variety of reasons
let's say we have the next president
people decide that voting rights are not
going to be applied to
in you know birmingham alabama
right and they're going to be a
sanctuary city for that there's all
these complexities around it
i made some commercials about
black leadership calling for
a lack of violence in the protests
keisha lance bottom the mayor of atlanta
gave a speech
that i think was a speech with the most
thundering moral authority that i've
heard from a public figure when atlanta
was tearing itself apart it's
extraordinary speech
i reference try to reference other
people the only blowback that i got from
that
was from um incredibly affluent
um sort of coastal elite
saying how dare you you know selectively
quote
you know african-american people
decrying violence you know when they
watch somebody get murdered and they're
protesting how they can and it's the
epitome of white privilege and it's all
the stuff and
what's interesting is i've long thought
that trump works through projection
like trump will everything with trump
that he that he makes is a claim for
others there's a lot of projection that
goes on and i've increasingly seen that
from aspects of the left where i thought
wow
how far do you have to be removed from
the ramifications of violence
to not be worried like how many houses
and mansions
and security guards and gated
communities you have to have access to
to be unconcerned with violent action
whether that community is a community of
color
right whether it's a white working class
community to simply say
violent protest is something that we're
not for like how dare you advocate that
when you're rich enough to never have to
be there
when the tourist violent um
protesters leave and the let's say the
black community is left there with the
wreckage of their community
like to be opposed to that message is
basically saying
i want to keep letting people protest as
loud as they want it's in a way that
won't ever affect me
or my children aren't at risk my
family's not at risk my house doesn't
feel at risk
but i'll use all the right language so
that i can be protected and sort of
maintain all of that
and when you're trying to wade in to
really like win an election
so that we don't you know the
african-american community doesn't have
to contend with another
with more i'll call it um
more voter rights being thrown out like
real concrete issues there's real
concrete issues there
but if you can chirp about something
that's a slogan like that you don't have
to get into the real
solutions or fixes but at the same time
right but you can you can take on the
you can take on the assumed status of
someone who's actually working
to solve the problem i think a lot of
that a lot of politically correct
language
i don't know i guess that would be
language that's in alignment with uh
with with any given doctrine is an
attempt to
take on the moral virtues of that
doctrine without necessarily having
to bear any of the responsibility for
actions in alignment with that doctrine
or
to bear any responsibility for the
consequences
like i was furious i was furious when
the protest erupted with jordan floyd
they were video after video of african
americans protesting
some of them were like telling you know
turning in people who were either you
know
anarchists who were throwing bricks into
and committing property damage
of saying you know grabbing people
handing them over to the police a lot of
people in african american community
were like this is our community we live
here
and of course i'm not implying that
nobody in the african immune
african-american community um crossed
the line in the course of those protests
i'm not saying that but i'm saying there
was an awareness within that community
that when the cameras are gone and the
lights go up nobody's gonna come in and
rebuild that community
and when all the tourists leave and
everybody's had their march and their
protest
they have to contend with it and there
was a measure of discipline in that
community whether it was keisha lance
bottoms i think the
the president of the naacp in either
oregon or washington had a great op-ed
killer mike the rapper was out there
saying we cannot have violence we're not
tearing down our own city this isn't
simple disobedience the point of civil
disobedience of course is
that you bear the cost you bear the
moral responsibility of your
transgression right right
exactly african community understood
this by and large
and a lot of the loudest voices who were
protesting against
it who who were for me was a frustration
we're from
incredibly affluent and here i'll use
the word privilege which i don't like to
use
um people in the white community and
that for me was it's a similar kind of
projection as i would see trump doing
like there's screaming about privilege
all the time and you're like how do how
do you not understand that
the destruction of property destruction
of small businesses risks to families
look somebody i'll give you a stat
that's an interesting stat here
the average voter who voted for obama
and then trump
thinks about politics on average four
minutes a week
four minutes a week right so people in
the bubble think
don't think about politics four minutes
a week and so four minutes a week is
about what you can manage to worry about
the emoluments clause
and russian hacking when you're at the
bottom of maslow's hierarchy of needs
right you got a sick kid
you're out of health insurance and you
don't have a job you might have a
special needs kid you might have a
parent in a home you have covet hitting
you don't have time for any of this you
don't have time to have the kinds of
conversations around nuance of
of weather and when everyone was shocked
about the about the latin vote
i was just thinking how many of you
people actually have friends and family
who are hispanic who you talked to
i mean the joke was that the big shock
was that biden won the
latin ex votes and trump won the latino
vote
uh-huh a lot of the latino community i
mean i mean
so what do you think accounted for
trump's attractiveness to the latino
community this kind of ties back in
this ties some back into a broader
question i want to ask you it's like
um i've been interested in what you've
been doing and
supporting it to the degree that i've
been able to and to the degree that
that's useful i suppose because
i was very interested in your um
willingness to look at what had gone
wrong with the democratic
democratic party and to try to fix that
that seemed to me to be a win
no matter that's a win for everyone no
matter where they are on the political
spectrum because
the higher the function of both parties
the better the political outcome as far
as i'm concerned right you want as
little stupidity as possible all across
the spectrum
so it seemed to me that re reducing some
of the foolishness
that characterized particularly the
radical left the careless radical left
within the democratic party and focusing
on a more
pragmatic let's say but also a
wiser and less resentment driven
strategy would
be a good thing overall um
so that opens up the broader can of
worms which is what exactly had the
democrats done
so badly that they lost to trump
well so to me there's a couple things
and we can talk about the hispanic vote
we should talk about let's let's talk
about that specifically and the broader
question in general well so look if you
i mean i have friends and family
who there's there's such an array of we
talk about the hispanic vote like it's a
monolith
right it's not remotely that cuban
americans are like anything
ever resembling socialism i will never
vote for you and if you compare trump to
fidel castro read a [__] book
that's basically the attitude of the
cuban americans excuse my language
it's it's it's and they say i don't care
what he calls us i don't care what he
does to us the only thing that we have
learned that we learned
out of that is that the only power that
you can trust is economic power
the rest of it's an illusion and
socialism wants to come in and threaten
that
i want business opportunity right i want
less regulations
they won't go near us it's very very
different and the hispanic community is
it's it's incredible so you think that's
particularly true of the cuban americans
human venezuelan americans venezuelans
yeah well they have reason for it
like like my most can a lot of the most
conservative
friends and associates who i have
whether it's it's people who are friends
of mine whether it's workers or mexican
americans in la
they also they don't want mexico to come
over here they don't want open borders
many of them
they left that why is that hard to
understand
they tend to be you know cat catholic
families
so if you think about politics for four
minutes a week and
somebody comes in all of a sudden and
they're talking about socialism
defunding the police
and then announcing all sorts of gender
complexities you know and i say this is
somebody with a
you know i always i i i preface it to
say you know i have a i have a trans
godson uh you know lesbian sister this
is not like where my personal politics
are
for what people should be allowed to do
where my personal politics fall
are very different than what i think the
priority and
and the ranking of discussion is if
you're gonna go talk to somebody who
thinks about politics for four minutes a
week and bring up
elaborate critical race theory and and
like and start to talk them about the
fact that boys aren't boys and girls
aren't girls and they
should just announce this and have
announcements at the age of 18.
i don't think any democrats grasp when
you think about politics four minutes a
week and they talk about trump and his
transgressions which i believe
are more damaging and dangerous than
those of the left
but i don't think anybody has any idea
the kind of transgressions that that
represents
to people who are either on the center
or on the right
so the four minutes a week thing really
is interesting too because
one of the things i was really struck by
over the last
four years with all my encounters with
journalists
many of which were good by the way i had
lots of good encounters with journalists
but
the worst encounters i ever had were
always almost always with journalists as
well
is that the journalists think about the
world politically
all the time like their every single
decision they make every
i mean obviously this is a
generalization but if you're in that
world
everything is political but for the
typical person
that's just not the case at all and
that's actually good one of the best
political science theories i ever read
was predicated on the idea or put forth
the idea that
in a highly functioning political system
especially a democratic system
the less people think about politics the
better the system is working towards the
end i didn't think politically at all
i'm not even interested in politics
you know i didn't i didn't i mean it's
i couldn't agree with that more i mean
one of the things i think a lot about is
i have i have a friend one of my closest
friends who you've met born again
christian he was raised as a son of a
missionary
um all through other parts of the world
and you know but he lives in la
he he worked a bit in the industry a
very
um rounded conservative friend of mine
he has gay friends
friends from whatever but he went in the
booth and told me during the election in
2016 he said i just went in and i
thought
forget it i'm voting for trump i can't i
can't bring myself to vote for hillary
clinton
i was really angry at him at first
because it was like
and then i realized i shouldn't say
really angry with him but i was i i
realized that
i didn't understand that for the things
that i saw for the clouds i saw massing
on the horizon
with donald trump and we're seeing some
of that here with his
the legal threats to the election trying
to undermine election security his own
large largely appointed republican
judges shooting a lot of that down
there's a lot of things we don't need to
get into all that because
everyone can have an answer for
everything that i say but the
realization i had with him was oh my god
he is a canary of a particular coal mine
he's a guy rides a motorcycle he likes
guns he likes kind of different kinds of
freedoms he
in a different he has a different
relationship with freedoms versus
security than i do
i'm a canary down a different coal mine
right part of that might be from me
looking at the sort of authoritarian
shadowyness that i saw coming in with
trump
that's what i alert to i can't decide
that my friend who i know and love
and who has been in my house and accepts
my friends my family everybody and has a
broad range of friends and family
i can't determine that he's either
foolish
or dumb or wrong or a bad person anymore
i can't determine that he's an ignorant
canary down in ignorant coal mine right
because if he's my friend and i'm that
close to him and he's here in la
and that's a choice he made i better
listen to what that was
even if the gut instinct for him and so
then i was thinking about this a lot and
one of the things that i think has been
a blessing of the trump presidency is
there's some conversations we're having
now that are that are awful and hard
like it's sort of like you know it's
it's
we talk about this all the time
obviously with young with freud you get
you go through hell before you get
anywhere else
we wouldn't be having any of these
conversations if we were now
in year four of a hillary clinton
presidency we're having different
conversations
they're worse right now in a lot of ways
about race about class
but the the fact that has stuck with me
the most and and one of the things i'll
say is i went in
open-eyed all the way down to assess my
party in the political situation
i've only gotten more disillusioned and
angry with the democratic party okay
okay so okay so let's let's go return to
that
okay i'm going to keep that in mind
let's return to that so
you put together this team or this team
was organized to produce
messages that would support
the democrat democratic party
fundamentally
but the but the overarching philosophy
was one of self-criticism let's say
if the self includes the democratic
party
and what other
what are the rules what were the other
rules for the messaging
see i don't think people are going to
understand exactly what you did you made
these ads but you went out and did it
with your own team
and so who are the ads generated how are
the ads generated who are they targeted
to
what was their consequence and what were
what were the rules that you used and
agreed on
when you were making the ads and how did
you agree on them
sorry that's a lot of questions but part
of this is it was so it was all
entrepreneurial jordan it was all
outside of the politic
if i i'd still be waiting for the first
approval from the d
trip c to do my first you know 2 000
commercial we couldn't wait for it the
the fifth domes and baileywicks within
the party and the institutional
just bureaucratic mess is sufficient
that that
a lot of what got done got done with a
network of people entrepreneurially and
free market
right that's pretty funny really so
publicans
yeah yeah and it gave rise to it and
really
all that it was was was our own ethical
bearing
you know i ran the thing and so i we did
testing to make sure we were that the
ads were effective that we weren't just
shouting at each other on twitter and
getting the most likes
and what would how define effective
how do you know i mean there's a woman
who's incredible who did you know we did
testing focus groups we saw
how they move people i mean i can send
you deck after deck after deck of the
analysis
okay so you were looking at you were
looking at pre
uh post-exposure shift in political
attitude as a consequence of the
that's right advertisements what was
nice was that our gut
instinct me and by that i mean me
marshall billy leader sean
our gut instinct was we're not going to
make trump bashing ads
we made some when they were fair that
was a big important thing like i did the
one with for republican voters against
trump
where it was uh it was just reagan city
on a hill speech
and i just showed where you get i just
showed trump doing the opposite in every
regard
for the first time in our memory many
americans are asking
does history still have a place for
america there are some who answer no
and we must tell our children not to
dream as we once dreamed
together tonight let us say that america
is still united still strong still
compassionate
still willing to stand by those who are
persecuted or alone
for those who are victims of police
states or government-induced torture or
terror
let us speak for them i believe we can
embark on a new age of reform in this
country
that will make government again
responsive to people
we can fight corruption while we work to
bring into our government
women and men of competence and high
integrity tomorrow you will be making a
choice between different visions of the
future
are you more confident that our economy
will create productive work for our
society
or are you less confident do you feel
you can keep the job you have or gain a
job if you don't have one
are you pleased with the ability of
young people to buy a home
of the elderly to live their remaining
years in happiness
of our youngsters to take pride in the
world we have built for them
are you convinced that we have earned
the respect of the world and our allies
let us resolve tonight that young
americans will always find a city of
hope
in a country that is free and let us
resolve they will say of our day
and of our generation that we did keep
faith with our god
that we did act worthy of ourselves that
we did protect and pass on lovingly
that shining city on a hill
[Music]
in the op-eds i i was equally harsh on
democrats and republicans both
um but you know so part of it was for me
as i said we can never
lie to any standard i don't want to bend
the truth i don't want to lie i went out
and got a hardcore lifelong wall street
republican to do all the fact checking
and it was down to like even if we were
kind of bullshitty about something
um so you mean he'd respond
sorry you asked him to tell you if he
thought that you had been
even playing with the truth rather than
breaking it oh and
i paid him as a researcher to say you
know here's the claims we're making
are they fair check multiple sources and
i wanted somebody who expressly was not
a democrat to do all of that yeah well
that seems to me
to be you'd want to have someone like
that around you if you're making complex
political decisions
that's right you need an enemy to tell
you
to point out your weaknesses okay so you
set up this crew
which was quite large to begin with and
then got smaller
you went and met with democrat leaders
yeah we spoke we spoke marshall and i
address both caucuses
and we still we in an ongoing way we do
candidate training and we deal with we
deal with leadership
also so how is it that you managed to
look one of the things you said was that
had you waited around for permission
you'd still be waiting and then another
thing that needs to be
pointed out to people is that without
permission you could go ahead anyways
and
make your political statement right you
just had to go do it
but you still have positive
relationships with
the democratic party per se now isn't
that weird how the hell do you account
for that why not because i was
because i was fair and i was respectful
and what we did was you know it's like
that judge's description of pornography
i don't know what it is but i know it
when i see it
so marshall and i would say look we know
how to make a unifying
uplifting message that's positive that
brings back sort of core democratic
values and can speak across the aisle to
people with a psychological profile
that's more conservative
with an understanding and respect for
the fact that conservatives and liberals
in concert are what hold society
together now marshall and i have an
opinion that is
that the bad the dangerous
aspects of the left are embodied mostly
in
academia culture
um let's call it journalism and then a
small tiny cabal
of very far left members of the
democratic party and to some extent it's
crept through the party some of the
things that are the excess of the left
that
that obviously you've discussed the
great lanes
for us on the right it is it is
codified all the way through the senate
all the way up to donald trump who holds
the nuclear football
so i was trying to figure out well why
does this threat from the left that to
me is
is is much less but just as dangerous
and there's a lot of canaries in coal
mines going hey man pay attention
that's bad news the same way that we
were about trump
why is it being given kind of this
um equal if not more waiting to the to
what i felt was the clear and present
danger
of the excesses of the trump
administration and what was happening
there
and so part of it was is is
the respectful conversation with trump
voters or mostly i'm sure i screwed up
plenty but you know
and and to do a unifying message and to
show them one of the things people don't
realize is this
is that messaging messaging becomes
content if we could get the message
right
we could solidify the story and then
that could change
policy and then that can change the
democratic platform so
we talked a lot about that when when you
first embarked on this venture
so and correct me if i'm wrong about any
as far as you're concerned about
anything that i'm saying
the first thing is is that if you
produce a message a story
that story has an ethic has an implicit
ethic
and if the story is accepted then the
implicit ethic is accepted
and then the implicit ethic will be made
explicit across time
so a story is like it's like the the
seed ground
for for explicit policy
so you took you you got a hand you got a
grip
on the story now one of the things that
concerned me about
the radical left was that because they
had a story and it's a powerful
mythological story um benevolent nature
tyrannical culture
the noble savage that's another part of
it
um because they had a coherent story
they had a disproportionate effect
on policy and the moderate
democracy so let me just interrupt okay
so if you look at so aoc did the green
new deal
push that through which to me was not an
adult piece of legislation it was a
trojan horse filled with everything
zero votes in the senate zero votes from
the democrats
every measure if you look at hr hr1 is
anti-corruption it was prescription drug
there was the the actual policies and
body of who the democrats
are is much more moderate and
pro-capitalist
um than than than it is in policy so
what's being parroted loudly
is not in fact democratic policy in my
estimation the flaw or the fault
in the democratic party is their failure
to stand up and keep the elements of the
party in their proper places
to state who they are to draw a line for
what they're opposed to
and i think that that act of them being
like well we can't really
we're concerned to criticize you know
defund the police or we're too concerned
yeah part of what i would say to them
was look if you're scared of
aoc's twitter following americans are
not going to deem you to be worthy of
carrying the nuclear football like
that's just a very low
checksum analysis if you can't just
clearly say that defunding the police
whether that means other things which it
does is it is a slogan that makes no
sense and terrifies the vast majority of
americans
rightly so and a ton of immigrants
rightly so
like or or you know people of hispanic
origin if you can't understand and state
that clearly because you're afraid of
the blowback
you're not going to be trusted to lead
and
that's and so it's a problem of of
degree and i think that's one of the
biggest
topics that of of friction you and i
have had for a long time
not not negative friction but just where
we've been hammering away at that where
i keep saying to you
the radical left is not the kind of
threat in america
relative to the threat that's posed by
donald trump as it represents in canada
um and we can disagree about that
because i think that the threats
represented by the radical left
represent and equally dystopian i can
tell you
like i don't really understand it myself
to some degree is that
i've been more and this is surprise to
me i would say
i've been more reactive to the threat
posed by the radical leftists
and i i think it's it's possible that
it's because i'm in academia
and so i can i tell you why i have a
theory about why that is too
okay yeah my theory is is that the right
the right comes in the front door
they're like here we are we want more
money we want more power we don't like
government we're going to shrink yet
even the the the let's call it
racism or anything that goes down from
that poll to in-group favoritism
right like normal in-group favoritism
there's plenty of people who are like
look i grew up in rural
north carolina i'm fine with having a
black president
i'm fine with doing whatever this is my
culture i don't want to be asked to
celebrate another culture
all the time in every way or else be
called racist that doesn't make sense to
me
whereas the left comes in and they say
well we like all of our stuff
and we like our whole situation like
like the examples i was giving earlier
we're gonna say defund the police when
we're rich enough to not be in a
neighborhood that that will have an
effect of
we we're we're above the pale that if
everything
is moved through that lens we're
successful enough that we have money and
we have resources anyways
and we're going to wrap ourselves in
sanctimony
right we're gonna wrap ourselves in
sanctimony want to maintain the status
quo as much as you do
but pretend it's because we're morally
superior and you're morally inferior
and that's that's a that's shame
inducing that's like a maternal scolding
instinct that elicits i think rage and
so
that's a that's a big difference in the
two and i think that accounts for why
some people are like hey
look it's it's just it's complicated
there's this element of moral
superiority and one of the things that
you know i did so much work with the
evangelical community
and they've been great like making good
faith arguments to reach out and talking
about you know
the values and attributes of christ and
trying to talk to voters and
there were some voters who who who we
were very successful in talking to
i want to say obama got 26 evangelical
vote hillary didn't go after it at all
she got 13 and lost and biden was back
up at 22-23
we thought that was a very important
community to talk to what people don't
realize
is if you look at trump if you look at
anybody from a christian world view
you can dislike every you can dislike
him legally you can dislike the policies
you can dislike a lot of these
politicians but the deeming of somebody
is morally inferior
right whether it's followers of trump
whether it's you know
voters no one can do that but god you're
not allowed to do that
you don't know where someone is on their
journey you don't know if he's a sinner
at the nadir of his existence and is
going to turn around and there's a
bigger weird
moral frame that gets put on this um
of course there's aspects of that that
will come in from the right
right with homosexuality with the more
racist element but
that aspect if if i if i'm arguing that
the
the the right has been more infected
up the power structure by the worst
authoritarian excesses of the right
i think that the narrative of moral
judgment has infected a wider swath of
the left
if that makes sense well it's worth
thinking about anyways i mean it's a
real mystery to me because
i suspect that if i particularly because
i'm canadian and so
that that puts me culturally
to the left of the typical american
let's say i suspect if i
read through a list of policy decisions
made by the democrats and made by the
republicans over the last 20 years and
i was blind to the party who supported
it i would end up
supporting more democrat legislation
than republican legislation
but there's still something about
the radicals in in on the left that that
disturbed me
in a way that
look it's it's so here's another way to
look at it right we've all seen
cape fear right in cape fear
guy gets out of prison he goes after his
defense attorney criminals
who are escaped who do go after counsel
go after the defense attorney and not
after the prosecutor and the reason for
that is
percentage-wise and i believe that's
true i've heard that i haven't sourced
it but let's pretend it's true for the
sake of this
uh parallel i think a lot of what has
happened
is people figure the prosecutor's doing
their job
but if your defense attorney who's
supposed to be looking out for you
doesn't there's a different kind of
anger i think that's what the democrats
represent so it's a betrayal
yes i think that that's interesting
here's here's the uber statistic for
everything for me
that when i arrived at i felt like the
scales fell from my eyes
over the last 40 or 50 years
50 trillion dollars with a t have moved
from the bottom 90
of americans to the top 1
that's not through innovation
competition
and pure free market capitalism it's
just not it's corporate giveaways it's
lobbyists writing bills
it's there's a whole structure it's the
weird inevitability of the pareto
distribution
right the idea the the age-old law that
the rich get rich and the poor get
poorer
it's unbelievable unbelievably difficult
to keep that under control and it is
definitely something that destabilizes
societies
and that's the thing and it's been done
largely that 50 trillion
effects of globalization certainly play
a role in that but it's not like
all of a sudden everybody who's a ceo
got that much more
brilliant so this is the largest
transfer of wealth
i believe in history and it didn't go a
socialist way that's when everyone's
pulling their hair out about socialism
i i just look at it and go 50 trillion
dollars so
if you're a white working class and that
happened under obama that happened under
clinton yeah well that's but see that's
the peculiar thing is that it's
it's not self-evident that policy can
stop that
like one of the things i've been
terrified about since really learning
about the pareto distribution is
its implacability you know
as you pointed out this this
distribution happened
even under systems of governance or or
ideologies of governance that
hypothetically should have stopped it or
at least slowed it it'd be interesting
to find out if that transfer took place
more rapidly under republicans than
democrats or not
well i think that whatever it is if you
look at that one
fact that is a failing of basically
the entire ruling class in america
like that and part of you know i
realized that i had a moment of
realization i'm going to
tell you this it was really funny so you
know there was the tarp give after 9 11
there was a tarp bailout and the
airlines were in trouble and they were
bailed out
my statistics might be slightly wrong
but called 53
billion dollar bailout okay
when covet hit they needed another and
we were you know
us democrats were hopeful that that
would go into the workers and everyone
else it went into stock buyback so that
the stock prices rose
right 35 percent of the stock market is
foreign owned it was a straight
corporate giveaway that's a transfer of
wealth it didn't go back to the workers
that pissed me off when covid started
they asked for another bailout and it
was like the exact same number
call it 52 billion i got all mad i'm
like i'm gonna call marshall we're gonna
do commercial and i stopped for a minute
and i said
you know what i'm the [__] who's
being served by that
and i don't mean this in a
self-flatulating privileged way like
let me take a peek into my 401k guess
what stocks
i'm probably holding right a ton of
airline stock
so when there's a stock my back which i
can get angry about
part of the thing is to have a
realization to go look that's not
that's a good example because it shows
that's a good
what would you say that sheds an
interesting light on the implacability
of the pareto distribution it's like
you're part of the problem even though
you object to it ideologically and
you're part of the problem because of
where you sit
in the economic structure and right but
the thing is about this and you talk
about regulation
or policies not working which i want to
return to in a minute but part of what i
realized was
um that's not because i'm a good
investor
right because i'm smart that's right
free market
right not because you're cruel and
malevolent either
no it's not but this is not my investing
genius or the free market at work
right we don't have a transfer of wealth
of that extent going the other direction
and so part of it is like okay so i'm a
beneficiary so
what so what a solution for a lot of
things is
you know you give money you scream about
privilege and you self-flagellate
as far as i'm concerned that's that's
all a
self it's not a self-focused reaction as
opposed to me saying
how do we start to address that problem
and the thing is is
it it has to be partially partially
policy partially regulation we can't we
can no longer it is something that we
fight all the time
you know one of the things you just said
shed light
i think again for me on
my irritation with the left end of the
ideological spectrum is that
it's just too much to see people who
benefit say like
who are in a position like you are or
like i am in
because we're net beneficiaries of the
pareto distribution in a major way
now it seems to me too much for me to
also expect to be admired
as a a paragon of virtue in relationship
to my attitude towards the poor let's
say
because then i'm asking for too much i'm
asking to be a beneficiary of the system
the way it's set up now
and i'm asking to be admired for my
objection to the very system that is
enriching me
and the second one of those is too much
to ask for
and this the solution for that and like
when i had that realization i was like
huh
let me get on that let me look at
policies let's have an economic summit
like the one you and i did
like and i'm not claiming i'm gonna like
go out and fix the whole problem
but if all i do is sit around and go oh
i feel so guilty let me do a couple
think pieces about it and talk about
white privilege
it's a name it's just more self-focused
[__] for those people
who think about politics four minutes a
week because they can only afford to
think about politics for four minutes a
week
so what do we do and what i do is i try
to
advocate for you know policies that will
work even if some of those are
conservative policies right i mean i
have
a ton of people across the across the
aisle across the whole spectrum
who i'd reach out to what do you think
of this are there libertarian answers
there's got to be some
there's got to be some regulatory
answers because it's it's so out of
control
well hopefully because the the the end
of the
pareto game is that far too few people
have far too much of everything
and that's not even good for them i mean
you're not rich if you have to live in a
gated community
that's right that's a gilded cage you
know it's not
it's not an indication of wealth wealth
is when you can walk around your city
freely at night
that's wealth that's exactly it and so
that's so much of what
we arrived at in the messaging when we
try to talk to
people across the aisle country club
republicans let's say
there's a difference for me for people
who are at the wrong end of
people are at the wrong end of this
system and and it pisses me off
when people get so angry about the fact
that like all these people are voting
in ways that hurt their own interests
right yeah i always say
like i vote in ways that hurt my own
interest i don't just vote like how do
you know what their interests are their
interests could be moral their interests
could be familial their interests could
be religious
it's not just their financial interests
first of all yeah their interest could
be their children's future rather than
their current re then their own current
reality
i mean i learned long time ago that that
small businessmen didn't vote for
socialist
policies in canada even when they were
pro-small business because they didn't
want to be small businessmen
they wanted to be big businessmen so
they were voting their dream not their
reality
and it's not obvious that that's a
mistake even though well
you could criticize it you could point
out it's lacks but it doesn't mean
it's inadequacies but that doesn't mean
that it's a mistake
so let's get into our the canary in the
coal mine discussion
again so i think like for me it's it's
glaringly apparent
and i know lots of people especially a
good number of people who are your
listeners will
in good faith disagree with me on that
to me it's glaringly apparent
the difference in terms of what a trump
presidency
let's say an abide in presidency in
terms of the relative levels of
corruption and undermining of the uh
democratic norms
i know there's a lot of
counter-arguments i'm happy to have all
of those but for the sake of this
discussion
what like from my perspective it's this
big slice here
like of a totem pole the vast majority
of americans are
so far down they're so far down below
that when they're looking up they can't
possibly distinguish some subtle
well you see trump it's an emoluments
clause and he's doing fundraisers on the
south lawn of the white house and that's
unacceptable
but the kind of fundraising and
enrichment that that like
you know the clintons did was different
for this other they can't
differentiate that so for me what is and
so then that gets to the question of
was the vote for trump like my friend
who went in that booth and said
forget it i don't care was that a wiser
thing because that's a higher
disagreeable irritation structure before
we get somebody who's even more
threatening from the right
right that's a good question it's
certainly
possible is the trump presidency
there's no way now that we can move
forward i think without having
much more robust and angry dialogue
about that 50 trillion dollar movement
from the bottom 90 to the top 1
right and there's some race
conversations beyond the
um i believe that this the the surface
stuff that we distract ourselves with
all the time like cultural appropriation
there's all these issues
and there's i've often thought and i'm
interrupting you partly because this is
such a crucial point
that distribution of wealth problem
i've i've come to believe that even
though
the left focuses on that
as the primary problem they actually
don't focus on it enough
because the attribution of the problem
is wrong
i don't think there's any evidence
whatsoever that the pareto distribution
is a secondary consequence of the
capitalist system so what that means to
me is that the left wingers aren't
actually taking the problem of relative
poverty seriously enough
because they've got a handful of
stock answers that have been applied
with absolutely no success whatsoever um
and they're more radical in their more
radical uh
guises they're not looking at the
problem with enough seriousness but the
problem exists and it doesn't exist too
because people are
malevolent or greedy although that might
add to it
it it's much it's much more complex
problem than
one that's much more difficult to solve
but some of the greediness like
the level of lobbying in in america and
with lobbyists literally submitting
bills and forgetting to take the lobby
firm's
heading off the paper there's an aspect
of that but the other way that i look at
that is to go
how badly did we fail as capitalists
and that's me right how badly did we
fail that enough people went
and picked up this shiny object called
socialism or democratic socialism which
is different from socialism
and think that that's a good idea yeah
that's a well that's a good question
that's that's the reverse of the
question the democrats should be asking
themselves
so the democrats should be asking
themselves well how did trump become so
attractive
what did we do wrong and the and the
right-wingers the more conservative
types should be asking
we haven't been we haven't solved the
problem of
wealth distribution well enough to stop
socialism from being attractive as an
option even though
the historical record with regards to
its more radical forms is dreadful
and we've also failed to embody the core
values
of free market capitalism innovation
competition where we have where we have
not pulled the ladder up behind us
where we have allowed and built a robust
system of smart capitalism
all the way down that is a solid
foundational base that we can stand on
to win
it's so god well so god damn difficult
it's so goddamn difficult though like
look let me give you an example so i
started a company
20 years ago and um
it struggled along for a long time and
then when i got better known it
that solved our marketing problem but
it's a psychological testing
company and when we first designed it
we designed we we consciously designed a
company that would
require no employees that would
that would would have no overhead and
that would be
um replicable so
it was computerized and and so it can
scale
without an increase in cost and like i'm
sensitive to the problems caused by the
preeta distribution
but when i set up that company i set it
up in a way that
absolutely contributed to it because we
don't pay any
no one in this company gets paid except
the three people that own it
that's it and
that's part of the inexorable i can't
say that damn word
inexorability i just did the audio
version of my book and i had to redo all
the
times i said inexorable because i said
it wrong anyways the it's
the end rex inexorability of the pareto
distribution is very difficult to
escape from be lovely if we could have a
discussion politically where
that problem became central and
everyone's attention could be focused on
that that the capitalists who
we could admire at least in some guises
could sit down and say look we have to
figure out how to get
more money to the bottom part of the
population within
this within a structure that can also
generate wealth because of course
capitalism does that extremely well
so that problem has to be brought to the
forefront the thing is the the further i
got into this jordan the more that i
realized that that everything
foundationally
is moral that's it you said once to me
and i think like shortly after college
you said there's only moral decisions
that's it i was like that's so weird
though because sometimes there's
pragmatics sometimes there's something
and the more you look at that the more
it's borne out that in fact
like any shortcut you pay for any
shortcut
pushes i mean look we don't have to get
all into jungian synchronicity but you
know that drill
and so one of the things that i think
about a lot is that
we can argue as if we're sitting around
in college
right drinking and there's a libertarian
and there's a conservative there's a
liberal and we
or a democrat conservative and liberal
let's say and we all know what we're
going to say already
nothing that is cure ideologically will
ever work or function
and the only answer to it like for me
part of what i realized was i realized
i'm going to be arrogant enough to try
to go on an adventure
that tries to tell stories not
re-message the democrats that i'm lying
and repackaging and putting pig on a
lipstick that i can
make an argument for chris i think you
met lipstick on a pig
what did i say you said pig on a
lipstick which gives the ratio of pig to
lipstick
seriously wrong
[Laughter]
that should appeal to the trump trump
viewers of this of this uh
broadcast that's horrible that's that's
horrible
um but it's not about it can't be about
deception
right it has to be about making actual
arguments for why
the core liberal values that i believe
are most imperfectly but approximately
embodied by
the democrats can have appeal to
conservatives right and we've talked all
that big
hopefully you also tilt the democrats in
that direction like
by producing that message right it gives
them right
it gives them a center around which to
align
okay absolutely a necessary thing you
need that center
but here's the here's the complexity
that i realize is
we didn't make any money at all we said
everything is pro bono
and we didn't have any credit and we
wouldn't have done any of this like the
no permission part is like here we went
off and did it
but when there's a ton of money to be
made in advertising i mean we have
i sent you that article right there's an
estimate that we created
you know and it it could very well be
off or overblown but there's an estimate
that the ad structures that we put in
place created a billion dollars of
advertising we and we aimed it at the
swing states we aimed it evangelicals
we aimed it at hispanic communities and
and the places that really mattered a
lot
that's a lot of value even if it's off
by 50
and the thing is is part of how we got
there was people when they do an
ad buy with a commercial they make money
on the ad buy
right and so part of it was we'd go off
we'd make some commercial we'd test it
we'd make sure that it was honest it
would be saying something that's
slightly different
but the cost of having our message
conveyed
in a way that might hope to be
transformational
was for us to give it to them and say
here say that you did it and if there's
any sales or anything to do with it you
go make a bunch of money off it
and just say it was you and so that's
the price of it because
if we said well we want to be cut in on
the revenue streams
then they'd have a bunch of reasons to
choose their own creative over our
creative right
right so what you did by taking yourself
out of the fee structure you enabled
your voice
that's right and we allowed for other
people it's like you don't get to have
all these things right that's
we get to have all the credit and make a
ton of money
and also be adored by the democratic
institute establishment
and then also be transformative and so
i'm not saying that like it's any great
shakes morally but that was the part of
me that was like
the solution isn't in doing the solution
is in when i realized the airline buyout
thing that i was an inadvertent
recipient of that in a way
it's kind of rigged that's kind of a
rigged game when there's a buyout and
there's a stock buyout and i just make
more money despite them being in failure
is to do stuff and to try and do stuff
properly and so i think that a lot of it
is we have such a failure
of moral leadership right now in
corporations i mean i was thinking back
to like
would it be amazing if we looked up to
you know more leaders of industry
and more for the it's just
we're so removed from our paragons from
our avatars of meaning i guess is what i
mean to say
like the fact that a politician's
supposed to be there to help you and to
do good for the community is almost
laughable now
the fact that a college or university
represents the
production of a renaissance man or woman
in pure form i mean the the lie of that
i think was laid bare by that college
admissions scandal people were so
furious about it because the answer to
that should be
no kid could cheat to get a university
they'd wash out in the first month
if they didn't deserve to be there in a
way so
we're removing ourselves like the
money-making mechanism of business like
great businesses and business people
should be building a whole
pyramid and structure of success under
them that's how you win
well part of part of that again is it's
a
that's a time frame problem you know
is that the more fundamental
the more morally fundamental a decision
is
the longer the time frame over which it
operates
and so you might expect
people who are benefiting from the
capitalist system to set up their
structures so that
capitalism itself would be supported
across a long span of time and that
would mean
cutting in the people that in the bottom
of the
hierarchy but short-term considerations
arise to
make doing such things very very
difficult
right and if you keep do it if you keep
making it difficult another eight
ten twelve years then aoc is the
president and the whole system's gonna
change
let's say right well that's the risk if
the system
if the system fails enough people then
there's enough people who who are
willing to
especially young men who are willing to
um
[Music]
take their chances in the revolution you
know at least it's exciting
so here's the hardest thing that i had
to figure out
which was this i had an okay time i
think part of this is my
i've always had a very diverse
background of friends because i write
thrillers i have a lot of friends in
military community a lot of kind of
hardcore conservatives
the hardest thing for me was to try to
apply the same
self-awareness of my blind spots and
i don't say empathy but sort of seek to
really
understand the further elements of the
left
that was the hardest thing for me
instead of just saying
you're idiots and you're squawking
you're doing all this stuff to really
slow down and listen and understand that
a lot of these younger
especially the younger kids younger
um who are coming up who are very
attracted to democratic socialism who
are way more radical
in a lot of their views than are
appealing to me when i stopped and
looked at the world through their
perspective and could get over my
inherent
like um you're always more angry at your
own side
in some ways but man if i was i have
you know my wife's a college professor
as you know and she teaches at
csun which which is a lot of the kids
cal state
northridge a lot of kids from tough
backgrounds like they don't have time to
be political those are the kids she has
they're working two jobs there's help
support their family they're raising
their younger sibling
like these are working kids so many of
those kids come out of
and they made the right choices not
drugs not you know
didn't wind up in prison they went and
did this they're holding their family
together
they have like a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in debt coming out
and there aren't jobs that they're
earning you know maybe they have a
master's in psychology at the end of it
and they're
they're making thirty three dollars an
hour oh you know okay
so that's that's so that means the the
price to buy into the system
at a point where you have a chance of
thriving
can't get too high so student load debt
would would certainly
contribute to that as would the price
entry price of of
real estate that's right okay so so
that's a real danger so
um but i think that people are why would
you look at other means and other
systems and why wouldn't you just
criticize the system
and for us to come along me to come
along and say well that's ridiculous and
democratic socialism and do you fund the
like all these things you're talking
about the system are so full i think
i think you could look the other thing
that you can you can
credit the especially young people who
are attracted to the farther left ideals
is that
there is genuine concern about the
unfairness of the economic distribution
it's like right and you know so there
are a lot of poor people
who are at zero which is a hell of a
place to be because
you get to the point where you can't get
out because every
you need what i don't know how to say it
exactly
you can't afford a bank account you
can't afford an address
like you can't get the basic necessities
that would allow you to play in the
system
you can't afford twenty dollars a month
the fee to keep your bank account open
if you're under a thousand dollars right
right exactly exactly that and so that's
the cost of being stuck at zero and
young people look at that and they think
well that's a terrible waste of human
resources which it is
and it's dreadfully unfair which it is
now
the the problem is is that the solutions
that are conjured up
on the radical left don't seem to work
but i think
not well anyways so i think it's
reasonable to say you can be sympathetic
to
the motivations that drive the
attraction to those theories
and it would be lovely if they work but
so many so many of them when put into
practice don't produce the result that's
intended
like i don't see any evidence i've i've
looked and it's
it's tough to parse through it but it
isn't
the evidence that left-wing governments
had have been better at controlling
the pareto distribution problem than
right-wing governments is very
it's very sparse and that actually is
unbelievably disheartening
but i think we're down i think we're
getting too academic abstract with it in
a way and i think the part of it is to
say
when they say that we go here's a bunch
of facts
and to me that's the same thing with a
mega voter let's say of me coming in and
going here's a bunch of facts about
donald trump's corruption
rather than joining and saying look
you know you're 22 you're not supposed
to have a world
economic view and an understanding of
the whole breadth of history
especially from our academic systems
that are failing you
as you're under crippling debt and
you're addicted to screens because
companies have
hired teams of addiction specialists to
you know
throw shrapnel in your nervous system
and the biomed companies are all over
you
they're being devoured from every angle
and we're coming in with powerpoint
presentations about why it's dumb rather
than going god
you're right there's a lot of problems
here and you're on your
maybe some of the language and reasons
and reasoning that you're
that you're moving towards aren't the
ones that will get you where you want to
be
but boy are you right about a lot let's
start from there then
like you can't change somebody's opinion
without seeking to understand them first
your motivations absolutely and you
shouldn't just assume that all the
positive motivations are on your side
okay i want to ask you some some other
questions here so
you um you produce 200 commercials we're
going to show
some of those interspersed in this in
this
video now
how were they distributed how many
people watched them that's the first
question
we did a ton of online digital
excuse me they they ranged some of them
we ran
during nfl games in swing states on
television
some of them like the reagan city on a
hill one one of the benefits was some of
the ones we did were really
innovative um in ways that are kind of
fun that we could talk about in
different ways
and so we got secondary like ours reagan
city on a hill one
brian williams asked james carvel about
that on the show so
there was also a secondary sort of
conversational
aspect of of crossover into mainstream
media in different ways because people
would then write
i did a whole series of asmr commercials
this is a fun what's asmr
oh it's the whisper do you remember
those videos where people would like
whisper and make sounds on the
microphone that were super trendy
no i must have been out of out of
function i must be malfunctioning during
that
period but so basically you know we
realized that the commercials that a lot
of the democratic
um agencies were putting were these like
you know trump
you know trump is beholden to china and
it would have the dark shadowy trump and
all the stuff
and so a lot of you know they got tons
of people are mashing the like button
and sharing it but what we found in some
of the testing
there's a brilliant woman we worked with
with the testing is it moved undecided
voters 10 points towards trump
and the reason for that is if your
nervous system is put into fight or
flight
by the ominous score and the facts then
you move
more towards you're more inclined or
receptive to conservative
messaging that's right jingoism
xenophobia strongman leadership yes
yes so i did this commercial series
where we hired um
a wonderful actress to to whisper it's
it's a sort of seductive whispering of
the mic
because i thought we need to talk to
voters nervous systems that's another
part of storytelling
right you're not talking just to their
prefrontal cortex you want to talk to
the
decision-making mechanisms we need to
lower the guard because there's so much
screaming about politics
and so that was what we did she said
there's so much screaming you know i
want to
i want to tell you this is the only way
we can cut through the noise and it's a
sort of whispered soft messaging
hi there it's just you and me
so after loading
everything else donald j
trump is loading our election
he hired his rich donner buddy
to slash the postal service so our votes
can't be counted voter
biggest crap
vote early
still some shell
so that was effective and then that got
written up in a bunch of places
secondarily so how many people are
typically viewing these ads
most of the ones that we did with big
launches were in the millions
and how would that compare to it well i
could say a typical political ad but
this is atypical because
the in some sense because the
technological infrastructure for doing
this is so new i don't know what you'd
compare it to
because i mean an ad used to be an
evanescent thing right you'd throw it up
on a tv
show and i mean it could run in
sequential tv shows but
the ad would run and then people
wouldn't have access to it now of course
they have access to everything all the
time
so i don't know and it's different i
mean it would be instagram it would be
facebook yeah it's on twitter then it's
shared widely
then some of them we cut down and we ran
on television stations
i mean but we got i think i could
confidently say we got over 100 million
views of stuff
if not more okay okay what kind of
um here's a nasty question
i suppose i would what good did you do
and what harm did you do
or what harm might have you done let's
start with good what good do you think
you did
within the democratic party let's say
but we have advocated and elevated the
purest place for me in the democratic
party are the first time house
candidates
that's the love for me to work with
because
it's so hard as people move up in the
structure and make all the compromises
that they have to make it gets more and
more sticky and the fiefdoms and
baileywicks and
and so the house candidates are
wonderful we supported them i mean i
think we
we had a big i i look i would say it's
so hard to say
and it's so hard to want to take
credit yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't want
to remove
our efforts from the midterm or from the
presidential i wouldn't be comfortable
removing them and thinking that the
outcome is the same now whether that's a
slice that we laid on top of
you know tons of people who did other
work and laid other slices down
community organizers the politicians you
know and yes the democratic institutions
with fundraising the dtripc
there's there is some credit that is
there too but we put and targeted
all of our messaging our theory of the
case was right we put it
straight into the swing stage we put it
straight into persuasion messaging for
moderate voters we went after a lot of
hispanic
um commercials like our theory of the
case was right we went after
evangelicals we did so what do you mean
but what do you mean by theory of the
case
we didn't do anything that was
politically correct
was ambitious it was unifying we had
diversity in our ads we did several
sort of black lives matter um you know
we had the lincoln project i got one to
them
but it was they were very um clean on
the parameters of what we were
representing as a unified positive
vision of america
and our our criticism i think some of
the commercials with trump here or there
we did get i probably i failed in
getting snarky in ways that might not
have been
as fair or persuasive so you did get
snarky in a way that was
so so was was not as persuasive here or
there
some of those 200 ads if i look back on
i'd go yeah
but i had an instinct and i'd send them
to testing and
i'd get the answer back i was like i
think i can try this way in
of this kind of attack route okay and we
got back that was like nope it's turning
people off again and i was wrong
so i was wrong plenty i mean i rushed
into being wrong
everywhere again and again and again we
didn't understand the permission
structures
we didn't understand the etiquette and
at a certain point we
you know early on it was funny i joke
with billy he'd send an email out to
like
a bunch of senators and heads of
different committees
and i'd get like a worried call from one
of our political people like you can't
you can't see all these people there's
all this internal you know
stuff going on and so the first reaction
is kind of chagrin or embarrassment of
like oh we stumbled
into you know this not knowing anything
but then we were like wait a minute
that's idiotic we're trying to win a
race if everything that you're saying
you believe
that trump is that damaging and
threatening we don't have time for any
of this
internecine [__] so knock it off
we're gonna see all of you we don't have
time to break that up
and everyone kind of went okay like we
were so
clueless in some ways that it almost
benefited us because
we were breaking a lot of established
norms in little ways
that that if people came up with it with
an issue about
whether it was some subtlety of language
policing or hierarchical stuff or
bureaucracy we just said we're not doing
any of that we're here to win
if you don't want to be involved we'll
take you right off but we're not going
to navigate any of those things
and since we since no one had given us
permission and no one was paying us
no one could fire us and so it just
worked it was really weird
well it is really weird that it was even
possible but
it's less weird when you the weird thing
is that you did this without
any payment that you just decided to do
it and
the second weird thing is that you
actually went ahead and did it and
as a project it worked even though the
outcome of it might be very difficult to
measure
um you illegal harm i did you ask about
the harmony well i also
i wanted to go more into the good first
though you talked about the
the newly elected people um you didn't
tie that exactly to the good that you've
done but there obviously is a link there
so i'm i'm just going to ask you to make
that more explicit that's the
they're the best home you know we have
amazing candidates
if you looked up alyssa slotkin if you
looked up dean phillips if you looked up
haley stevens if you looked up lucy
mcbath
um some people we lost this round
because of the bad messaging
really bad party messaging and inability
to draw a line against socialism in the
from the police
but we work with candidates like
michelle de la isla who's the mayor of
topeka in kansas
okay so you're you're pleased
about the effectiveness of your strategy
on raising the overall
capacity for performance of a new
generation or part of a new generation
of political decision makers
who i admire and who anybody would
anybody reasonable if you sat down with
with alyssa slotkin who was 20 years in
the cia
you might not agree with her on all the
politics it's impossible to not
completely admire her as a state's woman
she's she's an exceptional so you got
height
you think you were on the side of the
high quality people
yeah okay well that's cool all right
i mean it's hard for me to see and i got
us more oriented on getting things done
and accomplished
than talking about them theoretically
okay in terms of like here's how we get
[__] done
now it's enough with the abstract people
are hurting people are in a bad place
and i think also to some extent i've
helped to untangle
in in in small look it's so hard i think
i've done a lot in
i helped build a coalition i played a
role in stitching together
you know the rick wilson's and the david
frums and the
um bill crystals of course they're doing
it on their own and a lot of people had
reach
but i was the center of a particularly
diverse and interesting you know chris
halverson who you introduced me to right
the
former chaplain of the senate
evangelical leader there's there's
people who i
called and pulled into ventures in a
whole host of different ways
you know one of my favorite candidates
who lost this time due to bad
you know again messaging that was unfair
wonderful woman so she torres small
she was in the most rural district of
any democrat democrats don't tend rural
in new mexico
so i called chris halverson who you
introduced me to and i said she's a
she's a christian woman she's a woman of
faith she's bipartisan she's in the most
rural district
and she has concerns about rural
medicine or rural health care
and that's not predominantly democrat
who are who are republicans who you love
who you
can get her in touch with to help solve
that problem for constituents
it's a win for her that just helps
people in a rural district it's
politically agnostic and ideally we
would be politically acknowledged like i
would love to support
republican candidates who i felt like
were
you know good faith well that's that's
the question you know because you could
look at this as a zero-sum game and you
could say well
it's bad news for the conservatives if
better quality liberals emerge on the
political landscape because
their probability of victory is higher
but then you could take the opposite
viewpoint you could say no
everyone wins if the quality of
candidates on both sides of the spectrum
is or elevated if the quality is
elevated
and that's the only thing that keeps us
see i view the extremism like we're on a
seesaw
right and so the game theory is is that
if people are in the middle and they're
dealing with each other
like you know um tip o'neill and ronald
reagan
everyone can kind of be in the middle
and you think the see-saw but when one
group starts to move
and it's chicken or egg the other has to
move out to hold balance
and when you have the mainstream media
divided since essentially the gore vidal
william buckley junior debates and
there's a wonderful documentary the best
of it i saw it yeah yeah
yeah and you have social media driving
that way and you have
you know capitalism by appropriating
people for dopamine hits for the most
extremism online moving people that way
everybody's moved out and so part of it
for me is if we can bring the democrats
back
towards the middle yeah hope is we can
get republicans there and the other
thing yeah just well that
okay so that's that that well that's
that's the bet here right is that
and jordan what just one thing that i've
wanted to talk to you about this for
for a minute which is you know we talk
about moderates
and we talk about moderates and more
extremes and the distinction i make it's
like in psychology between process and
content in a way
like my politics are actually probably
significantly more progressive than
where i live
to to negotiate and understand that
within a system of governance
no one gets everything they want and we
need imperfect incremental progress
where everybody takes less of what they
want and so i think that there's an
aspect where we can talk about moderate
in in process
like i don't care how extreme within
reason of
reasonableness like aoc holding her
views i don't view that as some moral
issue if she was more willing to engage
on more fair terms about them
like i feel like we as a party could
sustain a democratic socialist
weighing in once in a while from a deep
blue district
to hold us to account for ways that
maybe we would get too tangled up in
corruption
it's all about the the ability to engage
properly
and then people's politics can be
wherever they are that's sort of that's
that is essentially the subordination of
ideology to the constitution in some
sense right is that
regardless of your stated goal and
regardless of your ideological position
you swear to abide by the process rules
right yeah well well and it could all
get certain that makes you a moderate
and that's reasonable a reasonable for
that makes you a kind of moderate and
it's a reasonable
okay i wanted to ask you two
what so i know that
the fact that you did this and the fact
that it was successful
at least as a project let's say and
probably because of its consequences
but certainly as a project because it's
been going on for four years and
manifested itself on a pretty large
scale
what were the consequences for you
personally
psychologically what did this do to you
how did it change you
wow that's a
it was one of the best and worst things
i ever went through in my life
i feel like it was like going to college
for four years
um i don't have a belief that we can so
i was
in large part engaged in the infowars
especially in acutely the last
seven months because i was on viewing
sort of people who are online are
largely radicalized and weaponized and i
don't mean that
flippantly i mean that some of the
playbooks that are issued
by the extremes politically are the isis
playbook
a lot of the opinions that we believe
that we hold are out of troll farms in
st petersburg
so we're here as a country when that 50
trillion dollars is moving
to the top one percent we actually
believe that we're
personally damaged if a black man kneels
on the sidelines of an nfl game to
peacefully protest
or a white girl gets dreadlocks at yale
like the things that we come to believe
are these giant stakes to me
are all the distraction games for the
movement of that 50 trillion dollars
to the one percent because we're not
talking about the prison industrial
complex right we're not talking about
the real stuff
and as we're fighting about this all
that keeps happening
so there is a a a view of the
level of corruption intricacy difficulty
that is that's dizzying
being in there and online i'm not sure
that that somebody can live
any substantial portion of their life
online in social media
and not be insane oh well it really it
like
it's it's it's like most of what i've
encountered online
or a huge portion of it has been
intensely positive
but even too positive i would say is
like so many people
comment in the comment section section
say on youtube that
being exposed to my work and it's based
on the ideas of other people like
it's not my work you know exactly
because no one's work is their work
exactly but being exposed to these ideas
which i've been
communicating let's say has so
positively changed their lives but
to hear that from thousands of people is
just it's overwhelming
like that's the positive side of it it's
too bloody much you get amplified too
much
and the negative side is just deadly
like
on on my youtube channel the positive to
negative comment ratio is about a
hundred to one you know and that's about
as good as you could ever hope for
but the positive ones are overwhelming
and the negative ones are
deadly and you know you see this because
people
people will get attacked by 20 people on
twitter
and they'll go into convulsions to
apologize and if you put yourself in the
center of this monstrosity
right that's multiplied by thousands or
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands and it's and it's not real
it's not real that's what's so crazy
it's not your family and your community
you don't know what cross-section that
is you don't know like if you're at high
school and there's one table of mean
kids screaming in the corner of a cafe
or
gossiping well it's real but it's
impossible to parameterize
you know with when it's your family or
or your immediate community you know
these people and
and you can put some walls around it you
can't give it the proper way no that's
what i mean that's what i mean you can't
give it the proper weight you don't know
what well it's because we're not adapted
to this environment it's like
and so here we have these our kids you
know who i i'm increasingly worried
about who were
were it's like it's like trying to exist
and go through puberty and go and enter
the academic world and the world of
culture and ideas
while being constantly um
blared at with the stream of the most
salacious
upsetting and activating
gossip that's been algorithmically
selected to target you
and that's how politics is that's what
we're dealing with
now i was in there and the thing is for
me is i talk to
i talk to anybody i mean you know that i
mean i'll talk to you
for a variety of reasons and um you know
one
there's all the obvious reasons for free
speech and talk to people who don't
agree with you
but also it's like a what are my blind
spots i always want to know
that's hard it's hard to go in i had a
one time i had a two hour conversation
with eric weinstein
you know about where he was on
everything but i was right in the middle
of it
that takes a while you know eric's
eric's incredibly bright i'm talking to
some of the brightest
most impassioned representatives all the
way around that's
all the spokes of the wheel that i could
get to and it takes yeah that's
confusing man
yeah and to find your center and to
accommodate and assimilate and eric
raises a ton of stuff he pokes at a ton
of
soft spots we're we're friendly it's a
very respectful
exchange but then to come out
incorporate the parts that are right
get clarity on where i think he's he's
skewed for his reasons and his
info tunnel that's different from my
info tunnel and i was doing it
in every direction and so it felt like
being torn apart to hold the center
because i was just being torn every
which way
well it makes me it gives me more
understanding even of why people will
settle into their ideological bubble
oh you know well it's a relief it's such
a relief you know because you got to ask
yourself just how many questions do you
want to ask yourself
right you know and i've always thought
that
exploration in the world of ideas is an
of unlimited value although you know i i
have a conservative element
um but man too much of it can tear you
apart
we have that like really really high
openness
yeah that's the danger of highway i
think for about
six or seven months that every day was a
deep dive into something that was
toxic and skewed to understand it to try
and
come back out and put myself together
and by the way going into it i
you know there's plenty of times you
cross someone who wants to destroy you
or scream at you or tell you why you're
awful
or make or you make an accidental
mistake like
when i was working when we were
discussing this a couple of years ago i
swiped one of your videos if you
remember and put a
voice over over it and you know i
thought that was warranted
i mean in retrospect i did it without
sufficient
consideration and i mean i realized that
very rapidly
i did a voice over of one of the videos
that you'd produce
because well i thought i had something
to say about it and i was irritated
about
well i was irritated we'll leave it at
that and
that was a big mistake and that caused a
tremendous amount of friction between
the two of us and
you know and it was also exposed to i
don't know a hundred thousand people
before i finally
took it down i didn't take it down
exactly but i modified it
but when you're when you're connected
in some high intensity fashion
your mistakes are exaggerated to a point
that's
just intolerable you know
and and again it's not something that
we're adapted to understanding it
i make a mistake and a million people
watch it it's like
it's it's the sort of thing that can
paralyze you into inaction
it's too much and the thing is there's
also like i was talking about that
there's no way to have a perfect
conversation about race class and gender
there was no way
for me to do this when i first was
trying to get democrats to go on
you rogan you know dave ben shapiro
right and i got i had some success i got
uh stanley mcchrystal i helped go to
talk to
to ben and to me sam harris had michael
bennett on
but they were people were really
tentative and afraid and so the only way
for me to do it was
for me to go on a lot of these first
well i was a novelist i wasn't
interested in all of a sudden being
put out there on the ledge necessarily
in that fashion especially for the
communities that i'm in especially as a
liberal
right in the community yeah but
i had to be sort of the case study for
it and you know i did it but what's
funny is there's no
if i look back at that there's there's a
hundred things i would say or do
differently there's no way to do that
without
well nobody's an expert at it it's like
right if you want to
move politically you're gonna do it
badly especially to begin with
so that's right and we don't and this is
one of the things that's troubled me a
lot
about you know so to answer your
question at the end of this i was
i was not in good shape for reasons you
and i can
get into later over bourbon in different
in more depth
i think i'll stick to sparkling water
given the state of my nervous system
sparkling water and salted meat i'll do
i'll drink enough bourbon for both of us
but you know
part of that process was
it's i don't know it's like there's
there's it's so much to go into
it's so much to dive down to really try
to figure it out to hold the
to really be open to what all those
blind spots are yeah and to come
at feeling like you're still um
intact and i had to i had to race to
make mistakes
that was i mean we spun up this whole
operation i mean it doesn't even make
any sense if i look back on it
the amount of stuff we got done you're
racing to make mistakes
you have that one lecture the full
proceeds the master and it was like how
quickly can i be a fool
on how many fronts the most rapidly is
possible to try and just get better i
mean
we were we were i mean we spun up an
entire you know
studio operation fundraising
distribution dissemination
network it was it was crazy um well and
then
i realized what was hard on you was what
the
the rate the the intensity that exposure
to the all the different opinions
the consequences of making a mistake
like if my let's say my theory of the
case had been wrong
and it should have been a further left
thing
and biden wasn't the guy and all this
other stuff and we'd lost because i put
call it that that that figure which
again i'm saying is slightly overblown
if i targeted a billion dollars in
advertising to the wrong people
giving the wrong message and blew the
mark and we lost the election by 104 000
votes instead of winning it by 104
000 votes that's a lot to live with and
i didn't even consider that until i was
so far in
that there kind of wasn't going out i
mean you can't consider everything as
you go
but the other thing is as i start i saw
with more and more clarity
i was i got way too much
not too much i had a ton of information
constantly
daily hourly about my blind spots and
confirmation biases
and a lot of anger and and
a lot of those things the upside of a
lot of those things your blind spots
your confirmation biases your prejudices
all those things
they protect you from being overwhelmed
like they're
they're they're they're compression
algorithms and
they remove information hordes of it a
lot of that information is valuable but
jesus it's like
how much information can you swallow i
mean it was so
that's right and what was what was
really and the only way that i
determined to make headway
in something that complex and that
corrupt and i don't mean entirely
corrupt but i mean you know
politics and with that much anger and
rage
and outrage and frustration and pain and
grief like there it was
it's it was was to try and go forth as
cleanly as possible and i
no one can do that i tried the same
thing you know because i was dealing
with people's
psychological problems and trying to
step very
carefully to not make a mistake but man
there's no not failing if you're doing
that all day every day with those stakes
multiple times a day and that'll eat you
up and part of what happened for me that
was so funny
i had two things that were funny which
you'll be amused particularly amused at
but so i got to the end of this and
i was really seeing things only in moral
terms what was interesting is at the end
of this
after the the week after the election
was really
i was pretty disregulated let's just say
most of the conversations i had were
with my conservative friends i called my
born again christian friends i called my
navy seals buddies
because i was seeing i was seeing
everything in like mythological
good and evil sort of terms and it's
like what was so funny was at the end of
this
exercise for liberalism right for
moving towards enlightenment discourse
moving towards um
a democratic party that i thought was
less imperfect
significantly less imperfect than the
than the imperfections of the republican
party as it stands under trump
was for me to need a lot of support from
from my conservative friends
unfortunately i have that what kind of
support did you get
why was it necessary to seek it out from
those sources
if you talk a lot about
mythology the seven deadly sins right if
if that's what you're
conscious of and seeing right because at
a certain point there's so much
information and you're so
open that you're just dealing constantly
with your own
failings right and you're seeing others
and you're trying to clean them up and
you're
it just it's almost like i got stripped
down on the bone
i don't have the sort of that the
particular courage and drive of my
friends who are seals who are in the
military
but this felt like it was my version of
of
of confronting things psychologically
that in the way that i could from a
position of much more relative safety
where i was getting torn apart and
trying to put back together
and conservatives are they understand
they understood that better and if i
start to talk about that
in ways uh in it's part of why i have
such a wheelhouse of
friends is like it all comes very
genuinely but also it's strategy you
know it's like
yeah it's you need people who think well
that's a
well that's a good that's that's an
interesting observation because
you know you could you could make the
claim that just as the world needs an
array of political viewpoints the full
array of political viewpoints
you know barring corruption let's say um
you need to surround yourself with a
full array of personalities
from conservative to liberal because
that way the bases are covered
and different people are going to be
different situations are going to call
for different people thank god there are
different people and
actually that's a good way to end this
is like thank god there are different
people
because no one can do everything all the
time
and so we specialize and that's true in
the political realm as well and
we need to understand that and not
assume that the conservatives are right
or the
liberals are right but to understand
that each of them is right
now and then well the thing is that it's
also
such an interesting part you brought up
that that um
disagreement that you and i had that was
pretty intense but we worked yeah and i
think
we'd work it out and you knew we'd work
it out yeah it shorted me right out you
know i mean i
yeah partly because i was tearing myself
apart about being impulsive and
also partly because of the magnitude of
the mistake the public nature of our
mistake let's say
you know when clearly because it also i
feel like when we went through that
we knew we would get through it we just
knew it would be rocky in a way
and what was interesting is what i found
was some of the people most adept at
pointing out my blind spots
when i then was in free fall as a result
of being subjected to
how many blind spots i had of course
they'd be the ones who would be able
to orient me right because they're the
ones who could see those things
right so that maybe that's part of the
thing too why
part of that was in that that week where
i was the most
acutely flailing let's say of course i'm
gonna go to the people who were the ones
who
had the most views that made me think
about things because i was like i feel
lost and spun
i'm not going to talk to people whose
views i feel like
that like that's a home base for me
because i'm not on my home base
i need different kind of impulse you
know and i think the same is true vice
versa
so you've pulled back what happens now
greg what's
like you must
you've graduated from your new college
let's say
and so that's a tremendous relief like
it is when you graduate from anything
when you accomplish something or when
you're finished with something but it's
also
leaves a huge hole um
you are obviously going to concentrate
on your writing again you have been you
have a new book coming out in january
what's the name of that book
prodigal son and your last book
the one that came out previously yeah
the fire they're they're
what i mean so what's happened that's so
amazing with this
i had a talk with a mutual friend of
ours a while ago talking about this and
i was like
for me one of the things that's been so
amazing is
the amount that i've learned and the
confluence with the series that i'm
writing now
with the orphan x and what he's doing
it's it's like bizarre
levels of synchronicity with us and so
it's funny because i'm i'm coming out
and going right into a draft of it yeah
right well you there's so
you know so much more i mean i've
watched you over the last four years you
know so much more
about the way things work than you did
before that that's got to have nothing
but a beneficial effect on your ability
to spin up stories
well to try to address them in that way
where it's easier
you know this is always why i started
you know i don't i don't want to write
and make propaganda right this was a
sort of necessity and it felt a bit like
a call of duty
but i want to write and have people
think through formats
that are one step removed through
science fiction right through the
thrillers through orphan x
and it's been really gratifying you know
as those as that series has built
that some of it's in there but so i'm
i'm having a renewed
love affair with that um it was a little
hard to take my hands off the steering
wheel with the politics and i'm sure
you know that feeling like when you're
just i was going so hard so long that
part of it was like well i should be
involved with these 50 things but i've
narrowed the scope i have a few pet
projects
i want to keep working in terms of
discussions with the event
evangelical community and doing across
the aisle
the anti-polarization stuff is really
yeah yeah i would
i really like well we did some of that
in washington when we were
bringing republicans and democrats um
congressmen and senators as well i
believe i
i was really unhappy when i couldn't do
that anymore because that was so
worthwhile and
the opportunity's still sitting there
and so hopefully my health will hold
i'd love to do that again it's such
gratifying work
we we should and i think what's funny
with that is it's like you know here you
and i
are all tingled up in different
political discussions in different ways
but neither of us were particularly
political
really you know it's like that never was
the
source or drawing well i always made a
decision i've had
to make a decision between politics and
other roots continually in my life and
always pick the alternative roots
yeah me too so all right well we should
wrap this up
i guess um yep we've covered a lot of
ground
i was really good talking to you great
time
we'll talk soon
[Music]
you